j'accueille maintenant ça triste ici
c'est l'en but
mm-69
vous
comment savoir
vous êtes ici pour l'américain donc le
minot film de patrick timsit avec
thierry lhermitte emilie dequenne
richard berry marianne denicourt et
lorànt deutsch
sortie le 7 juillet je faire le pitch ah
oui voir si j'y arrive on va voir si je
comprends oui alors c'est l'histoire
d'un mec persuadé qu'il est américain et
qui comprend pas pourquoi il n'a pas le
droit de vivre dans le pays qu'il aime
voilà c'est très clair c'est très bien
alors là c'est pas drôle mais je sais
très bien mais ça c'est le pitch
ils pensent américains ils mangent
américain il vit américain mais il est
français les chiens américains là et il
n'est pas né au bon endroit il est né
ici et thierry lhermitte la semaine
dernière parlé du film et il disait que
finalement c'est un peu comme un mec qui
les perçoit vite d'être une femme dans
un corps d'homme enfin transsexuels il
le dit d'ailleurs montré moins chier si
je voulais changer de sexe à ça veut
dire que c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
vouloir être américain canton ce quand
on est français on à droite se sentir
américains ou l'or c'est la liberté de
circulation c'est pourquoi on est né
quelque part on doit y rester
voilà voilà donc c'est un peu c'est le
sujet du film ben ça alors lorànt
deutsch dans le film donc grâce à
l'avocat thierry lhermitte va réussir à
inquiéter les états unis et a créé un
51e état du côté de merl est là c'est un
peu comme si le village d'astérix
demandé sans son attachement à rome quoi
oui c'est le village d'astérix mais il
veut être roma coin là j'ai voilà dans
des bus de promo non non non enfin guy
moment j'ai déjà dit non au milieu de la
promo pourquoi on sent déjà que tu en a
plein le cul de paraître
on m'a donné un sens c'est vous qui êtes
protéger leur sphère énergiquement avec
un évène la patate thierry bordel là qui
à l'époque c'est l'histoire d'un mec qui
est persuadé qu'il est rien et il
comprend pas pourquoi il n'a pas le
droit de vivre dans le pays qu'il a eus
américains ils mangent américain mais il
vit américain mais il est français il
est allé au bon endroit voilà mais grâce
à un avocat cynique et de croix qui
s'appelle thierry lhermitte
ils vont réussir à inquiéter les états
unis en décrétant les merlettes 51e état
des etats-unis va c'est un peu comme si
le village d'astérix demander son
rattachement à rome
en fait non
allez
je m'en vais jamais à temps alors vive
est tentante pour des gars qui sont
attentifs et un film et ou bien il peut
faire beaucoup mieux il y en a beaucoup
plus sous le capot il va te prouver donc
c'est l'histoire d'un mec est persuadé
qu'il est rien et il comprend pas
pourquoi il n'a pas le droit de vivre
dans le pays qu'ils aiment les
américains ils mangent america reggie
vie américain mini concert
il est allé au même endroit voilà mais
grâce à un avocat si nick et moi qui
s'appelle thierry derni ils vont réussir
à inquiéter les états unis en décrétant
les merlettes 51e état des etats-unis va
la tabaski le village d'astérix demander
son rattachement à allonger un peu
non non ce qu'on peut dire c'est la
deuxième ce qu'on peut lire ce qu'ils
voient les lavages parle qui me parlent
in ou pas est-ce qu'on peut dire c'est
qu'ils voient l'américain peu comme les
immigrants du xviiie un peu comme
l'eldorado
ben oui je l'espère ce que j'aimais tant
me prend les méfaits du tabac il a bien
pris à la télé tous les jours avant que
la fusion et la main du tube sommes
moins professionnel c'est ce que je
préfère leur espace situé à la perche je
te tend des perches je parle il aime pas
le mérite pour se caler pour ce qu'elle
représente exactement ce en amérique
c'est la mairie du divertissement le
coca cola c'est peter pan ou quoi c'est
à dire que son america lui c'est un peu
comme un monde imaginaire à monde perdue
qui existe plus que kepu comme il l'est
il s'attend à voir john wayne déboulé au
coin d'une rue pour sauver la veuve et
l'orphelin et il s'en fout de savoir ce
qui se passe et tout le contexte un
petit peu difficile aujourd'hui que
qu'englobe l'amérique lui pour lui c'est
pas du tout ce à quoi s'est vraiment
l'amérique d'hollywood de la dernière
séance qui aimait le cinéma fermé
aujourd'hui
la traînée qui fait trois quatre hôtels
et paul plan durable va bien alors si
vous faites ça va nous faire un break
oui c'est moi comment joueront téléphone
vous avez vous regardé votre caméra qui
s'est passé après attention à 2h de 2003
en aucun n'a les taux serge